Oh see ya sticks is a wild animal
Styx is a great addition to this group
of characters and before she becomes
part of our gang she's been living alone
in the wilderness for a really long time
and Styx has sort of become a little bit
nuts you can doubt me but I'll protect
you anyway because I'm a good friend and
because it distracts me from the
government agents that are replacing my
plants with violins she kind of like
lives in this other like alternate
universe that she thinks everyone else
is living in but you know they're not
she's really intelligent but the things
that she says come across as rather
strange to other people she loves
spending time in her burrow because
that's what she's used to and it keeps
her safe and when things are too freaky
for her she always goes back there Styx
and Amy are best buddies and it's a
really strange pairing ah she's fiercely
loyal to her friend and the thing is is
if she's around really truly nobody has
to worry because she can kick butt
sticks is very funny without trying to
be funny crossing paths where the
cross-eyed moose brings a curse upon the
moose cross an anon moose close friends
don't draw people nobody got science she
loves the fact now that she's got this
like group of buddies that she can hang
with because she never had that before
so I think it's always this sort of like
struggle like oh I want to go back in my
hole by myself because I'm not really
sure I can deal with this but I love you
guys look out for sonic boom coming soon
that mine I'm a poet